The joe rogan experience.
What's up man?
How are you?
Fantastic.
You're good.
I feel good.
And that fill the,
if it would not be for my,
uh,
I like,
all sore,
that ad there would be a feel I feel better than than I when I was 25.
What did,
what did you have your colitis?
Yeah.
Call ideas yet.
What is that?
What causes that?
We don't really know what it caused it,
but uh,
the best,
the best theory is that,
uh,
before my last fight with Michael Bisping,
I tried to put on weight extra weight.
So I followed a diet or program that I was eating every,
almost every two hours.
And um,
I think our system is like a car,
you know,
if you do a lot of mileage,
it overuse it.
And so that's what happened with the stress and everything.
During my training camp at big problem,
you know,
I couldn't sleep at crazy cramps.
You know,
sometime I add blood.
Even like when I went to the bathroom and I want to go do some tests because I
was worried that it was something more like,
I mean it's collide is very serious,
but that it was like cancer or something cause he had blood.
So I did some tests.
It came out and they get to live and I said to myself,
I said,
this fight being delayed,
delayed,
but postponed so many times that if I do something,
if I say that perfectly,
what is going on,
I'm going to lose the opportunity to fight for the title at one 85 so I,
I keep it shut and I told myself,
I said,
whatever it is,
I'll deal with it after the fight.
So I did the fight.
Everything went well.
Then afterward I went to do a,
it's called a colonoscopy.
They put a camera inside of you?
Yeah,
and I did,
I got diagnosed with also colliders.
That's probably be the mix of distress and also the,
the fact that I was constantly eating,
I was eating and it not only eating Joe,
I was trying to put on some weight.
It was very hard.
Sometime I was,
I remember many times I was having breakfast but I was regurgitating,
regurgitating my breakfast truing up cause you were just eating too much food
but add to,
because I needed to keep my seven a certain weight and def.
The crazy thing about it is first not realize it's a mistake.
I should never have done it.
But when I made the weight at the one 85 the day before the fight,
I could not go back up to a one 90 there's a,
the higher side was going back up so that they have that fight.
I woke up and I add a little breakfast.
I chew up my breakfast again.
Wow.
Yeah.
Wait.
I was really messed up.
Then I went to weigh myself.
I was like [inaudible] 91 they wow.
Yeah.
And what do you think Mike Wade,
you felt very strong.
I mean it's not really the weight at this time because
the way that you weigh right now,
depending on what you eat,
you have a lot of stuff inside your,
your your intestine and everything.
So you and also water retention.
I felt like I had a lot of water retention and,
um,
unnecessary weight.
Exactly.
So it's like dead weight.
The second bag that you carry on your shoulders show what I should have done,
I think is just stay the same way that I am.
My natural weight.
I think nobody has a way that it's his best wait to perform an athletic
performance.
And that's what I should have done.
Right.
But it was a mistake of my part.
It was a big mistake.
So you were just thinking that because you're going up to one 85 and you're
fighting a guy in Bisbing that used to fight at two oh five.
Exactly.
He's a pretty big guy.
That.
I taught that to perform better.
I needed to elevate my weight.
But by doing that I create,
I create the big problem of FEA healthy.
She was so,
and that,
that colitis didn't exist before that,
eh,
not that I got diagnosed for.
No,
no.
And uh,
I think that that's what trigger it.
And so after the fight,
now they've gone back to a normal diet.
Has it changed?
So,
so after that fight,
what happened?
And it's very interesting too,
I got an on medication and I met a doctor that,
his name is Jason Fung is in Toronto.
People can research,
has,
is amazing,
amazing guy.
And I met a doctor that,
that treat people with cancer and diabetes with the intermittent fasting.
So I started doing a program of intermitted fasting and time restricted eating
and all my symptoms diminish like every,
every week,
every month diminish.
So he's got the,
it's getting better.
It's not 100% now,
but he's getting out a lot better,
a lot better.
And I feel a lot better.
A lot of people eat like that now.
We had Ben Greenfield on yesterday who,
uh,
you know,
he's a,
a journalist,
does a lot of experimenting with his body,
thought a lot,
a lot of scientific stuff and scientific,
uh,
research on diet and in restricted eating is a big part of it.
He does a lot of that.
It's interesting because I'm,
we're conditioned to think that,
uh,
when,
I want to gain muscle,
don't want to get,
you know,
I need to eat more to accelerate my method,
but it isn't,
but I never felt better in my life if we would not be for that particular issue.
I feel better now.
I sleep better.
Uh,
I uh,
inflammation and I'll,
I'll also did a test in January.
I went to McGill university to do a scan of my,
uh,
my weight,
my purse,
my fat percentage,
my uh,
muscle density,
bone density and my,
I'm in five months.
I did it that few days ago.
Like not,
not this week,
the Tuesday of that last week.
And My,
uh,
my fuck person,
that dish has a decrease.
My muscle mass has increased and my weight is that,
that same than it was in January.
And you think this is all from restricted eating?
My,
my training did not have to change.
So they only thing has changed pretty much is the,
the,
the restricted restricted time eating and intermittent fasting.
Yes.
Yeah.
That intermittent fasting gives your digestive system a break and it lets your
body recuperate better.
I think that that's what had helped me out.
Uh,
the mostly I think that's what it is a it I felt like,
uh,
I was like,
like I said,
like a car.
I was,
he was putting too much for nothing.
And I think as human being,
we're overfed.
I,
um,
I'm very interested about paleontology and,
and also a history.
And I know that human being an enter gatherer time then not eat two meals a day.
No,
they maybe a few times a week.
But when they eat they eat a lot cause I need to do with fast.
So I think it's more natural for a human being to do so.
And also,
I now I read a lot of stuff and I watch a lot of stuff on the Internet.
How about intermittent fasting and time?
Restrict the day eating.
And I just wish,
I,
I knew that before,
uh,
for so many years.
I,
I used to follow the rules are we need to eat at least three times a day.
And you know,
I don't really care of what I eat,
but I,
I've,
you know,
even though in the morning I was not hungry,
I was always,
am I forcing myself to eat,
which is bad,
you know?
Okay.